are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
[ __ ] you and your debate uncle Joey
coming at you on a Monday [ __ ]
night October 10th 2016
it's my [ __ ] fight weak [ __ ]
Saturday night Saturday night
[ __ ]
Rosemont zany Saturday night two shows
who's my baby two shows two shows Friday
they're sold out all that's left is
Thursday suddenly in know [ __ ]
stories iliza shlesinger is in the house
we're going to do a few bong hits we'll
need a few stars I'm gonna eat a
mushroom cap and it's a [ __ ] regular
Monday night here at the at the Church
of what's happening now I haven't seen
you guys in a few days I've been busy
I didn't bring my special type tonight
my friend maybe a pipe over there and uh
and uh lumbus Ohio our sons of anarchy
meets Black Sabbath I left it on horizon
how was your weekend good anyway I like
women with balls
iliza shlesinger ever since I saw on TV
promising on that [ __ ] stage I knew
she had balls see our best friend Mike
my connection to you was Dan a break
damn would always feed me Eliza
information yeah I always say which one
otherwise I am for some reason you are
there or something you talk to him okay
so I was there after you and Danny goes
she was here if you sold a bunch of
tickets I always miss her I didn't know
who you were I just thought you but I I
like you so bleep what do you assume
whatever I got off and look at me with
his new MV empty watching [ __ ]
the price tonight
Rossini's they got the good steaks there
they go everything downtown
I won't downtown's are you dick put me
in a supplement like the [ __ ] time we
get over here with Uncle Joey it's a
Monday night October 10th ten ten ten
sixteen take your time but hurry up next
- I'll watch the baby what's the baby's
name
my little brother what's happened you
bad [ __ ] we're gonna go deep
tonight we got stars we got bombs
we got little we got over here look we
just grew up look at this the week did
your balls hang down the day we go all
over did you ever get the feeling that
they're really under ceiling that's for
usually just a little which one you on
that one
this one looks like my toenail exactly
take this one loosen my toenail in
there's a baby walker that's perfect
that's what you need you might be
getting ready for the Big C
there you go son just a quick swallow
the jeat the whole thing there he goes
there he goes
swallow quick [ __ ] there you go there
you go now we do a few stars tip down
that mushroom cap duck we don't [ __ ]
around here the church have been telling
you [ __ ] for a long time you
wanted dilly dally dilly dally somewhere
else you don't see their leaves when we
get started him he's uh yes
three
what alright some specialty of them at
the house plant I had kept treats with
CBD wall for your joints inside not
known TAC
you always got thicker your pets
he'll you can take the rest those of you
gonna show us some next time we do I
like Sunday at the store Sunday at the
stores not bad there's no dry oh no no
no no if I got home back no way I'll
tell them we go home for the weekend
something that is not a bad little shock
I bet it will have another Sunday it
sounded yeah babysitting will have no
idea
hey you started [ __ ] because you went on
Twitter after we left that thing of
people started hitting me up get her on
the podcast like I hit Joe Schwartz up
what a nice guy how long have you been
with Joe Schwartz good guy I'm gonna
call him after this
yeah I'm gonna take this special and
then I'm taking it down there just take
a ride and leave them down there I gotta
get out of my [ __ ] comfort zone on my
app a little [ __ ] bag I'd never get
out of my comfort zone I'm scared of
I'm a slave let's do one more we'll get
this podcast started that's it
how are you reading rather you see the W
Blanche what does blechy anything good
eat steak lobster when you're down
Blanche is like if I come over to this
side Joey Joey could give me a treat and
mama won't see that he's given it that's
how smart she is she came over here she
goes you know when the market
any advance on dissa menace in fact
we've got don't you see don't breathe
this stuff what what she's gonna come
after and that's it and that's that I
told you something big good Monday night
who's that who opens up the show with a
mushroom cap and his partner Lucy say
Shawn BM BM t watch brother thank you
that those are the watches we got your
Romans got these are the lunch baby nice
black on black
I'm telling you go to church CH you are
CH and get the discount whatever it is
I'm saying I'm not pushing I'm just
letting you guys know that's what time
is we got a good week tomorrow I'm at
The Comedy Store a the clock and then we
head off to Chicago thank you guys for
your support on this oh [ __ ] here we go
take a look back deep do you think one
more bomb do you want to sit there
talk about Dancing with the Stars it's a
great event tonight they're gonna do a
major production okay you're watching
Dancing with the Stars before it starts
get the gun put it in your mouth and
just shoot backwards let the [ __ ] be
empties
there's not cleanup it back to you Lee
Lee looking like Sinbad the sailors [ __ ]
playing [ __ ] love story goes
good work
yeah right there so burn it the way you
like is nice and black okay then it hit
it hit it Jack was no hit it
training [ __ ]
there's no lecture you didn't take a
bath on Saturday you take a pause my
daughter something that you got to keep
the [ __ ] things in shape what do you
think should lead another mushroom step
let's see it another blessing stand
those ten get the flag
ship ship Charlie hobaugh but this
Thank You Columbus thank you for these
what job brother
the shrooms of death tonight ladies and
gentlemen that's how we do it you
understand me what have you done on a
Monday night with your life we'll even
on your term paper
whoop-dee-doo you over here going deep
until the murky waters of the underworld
when the Batcave
where's Tommy Easton where's Larry
where's the rest of the crew we think oh
[ __ ]
take it you ready get this [ __ ]
started we'll be back in seven minutes
Lisa at uncle Joey and my main comedian
s tonight Aliza slash these are the best
I'll see you guys a seven minute state
line